[Music]
all right
look at that headline the josh allen
experience is a way of life in buffalo
you can read that fine story
in the ringer the author
of that piece really well done is nora
princioti
uh we hang out with noah every now and
then you know get her on the three-way
talk about football talk about life
what's up nora how you doing
i'm doing pretty well i love it we were
just talking about this i love hanging
out with you guys it's always a blast
and extra special today now that we get
to talk about josh allen
yeah well that's what i'm saying that
that story that story is really
well done i know
uh not the the greatest two weeks for
josh allen and losses to kansas city and
tennessee
but
i like the josh allen that you found the
josh allen that you uncovered there in
buffalo where
they have they have pinned everything on
him and they are they are believers that
he's the guy that right he's the next
great quarterback of buffalo right
yeah now buffalo buffalo they're
believers and they've been believers for
a couple of years when i certainly was
less of a believer than i might be now i
think i'm sort of incrementally gaining
belief in josh allen although the last
two weeks have have been um
maybe not
quite so affirming as the first few ones
were but the the heart of the story
it's kind of funny we can do a little
bit of journalism inside baseball here
but
the heart of the story is about how he's
just this chaotic guy right and
you never know what you're gonna get and
it's an interesting thing for a football
team to have to plan around
is someone who has really really
tantalizing skills but
is erratic and lacks some
you know some of the accuracy that was
missing in college and in the first
couple of seasons those traits that tend
to be essential for successful
quarterbacks but he does have this one
just kind of infectious quality to him
and two this tendency to just never give
up on a play in ways that can go
spectacularly right and spectacularly
wrong
and it was very funny to be sort of
planning the timing of the story over
the last couple of weeks and just going
if he doesn't have a good game against
the titans it's not like it invalidates
what we're saying because all we're
explaining is just that there are some
high highs and there are some low lows
and there have been fewer of those lows
this year and i think that's still true
but
i was living and dying with the josh
allen experience just based on my
publishing schedule over the last couple
of weeks but we figured that ahead of
the chiefs game
i don't know that
even in even on my most josh alleny day
i was thinking he was going to go
toe-to-toe with patrick mahomes so we
just we just kind of went for it
i want to talk to you about the chiefs
though because so yesterday like a lot
of people we talked about you know best
team in the nfl steelers make a
statement against cleveland
titans make something of a statement uh
with the comeback win against houston
but then there's of course the super
bowl champion chiefs
and
you know i thought you could be
impressive in a blowout but she could
also be
impressive in subtle ways nora in a nine
point win and by that i mean
you know you know what patrick mahomes
can do
for them to run it more often than i
think any andy reid team has for more
yards than any andy reid chiefs team has
and for patrick mahomes afterward to say
well the safety's played us so far back
we're going to run the ball if you play
us like that
and then for him to say yeah i had some
rpo options but i just kept handing it
off that kind of commitment to the run
from a past a past first team and
le'veon hasn't gotten there yet i say i
like to say nora like
how much of a statement and how scary
are the chiefs after last night
i think they're really scary and they
haven't been the juggernaut that we sort
of identify them as in
the last few games but i just think that
we need to kind of reframe not our
long-term expectations for them but the
week to week
expectations because they are
they're the best team in the nfl and
they're also the team that other teams
identify as the best team in the nfl
and that's a different way to go through
a 16-game schedule than being
the upstart
and the team that can take people by
surprise and so i think it's in a way
much more important to them right now to
be able to
win a game on the ground if they need to
if it's a sloppy cold wet day
they're playing the bills whose defense
hasn't been as great as they've been in
the last couple of years but still have
a good defense
they can do that
and i still think the scariest place to
be if you're an nfl defense is even if
it's third and long and you're playing
the chiefs i always think they're
converting that
so i think
being able to be
multiple and to win in different ways
i've been really impressed with some of
their defensive performances i was
incredibly impressed with their
performance against the ravens
and i think steve spagnolo deserves a
lot of credit with
the way that he's been able to
adjust week to week and have
be kind of a game plan defense in ways
that
we hadn't seen them be in in the first
couple of mahomes years
i just think they're they may not be
putting up 50 points a game very often
but they're so much savvier than they
used to be when they were younger and
when mahomes was just winning because
he's the greatest player in the in the
league and it doesn't really matter
like they're they're almost this like
savvy veteran team and so i'm just
i don't really care if the games are
closer i would be more scared to play
them than anybody else
yeah well it's funny you say that nora
because i told michael smith yesterday
that the bills are gonna beat the chiefs
outright
and i thought the secret i had i thought
i had a little bit of secret i had a
secret
and this is where i come away with with
respect and not a secret but re respect
say okay sean mcdermott knows andy reid
better than anybody he was there for 10
years he knows exactly what andy reid's
going to do game is going to be in
buffalo weather is not going to be great
the bills are coming off a disappointing
embarrassing loss to the titans this is
perfect
for an upset
and they still
went to another pitch
that we didn't know that they had so
i look at these defending super bowl
champions and this is not the year to
say they fell off maybe maybe it's next
year
but right now i think they are as you
said they are well positioned to uh go
back to the super bowl and
and maybe compete for it in a different
way
this they they have all those other
pitches right like we saw them not have
it
when the patriots beat them
twice in the season season and in the
afc championship game
they just ran the ball on them
and
they controlled time and possession they
kept the offense off the field and
that's it's totally logical to not build
a modern nfl team around being able to
stop that
and that defense was constructed to
defend the past but not the run and
that's going to get you really far
that's going to get you really far in
90 of your games but they ran into the
wrong team and they weren't ready to
adjust
and
i just don't think that they
are in that kind of situation anymore
and some of it's personnel but i just
think that they're
they're more seasoned they've just been
at this longer and i think they have a
better understanding of what teams try
to throw at them
and i think
they just
they never panic
and it's funny i think
we've seen it with the patriots right at
a certain point you develop it's an
actual skill to know how to go through a
season when all of your opponents are
going to be circling you on their
calendar and putting extra game planning
resources into that game like it's it's
a real thing and i think they're getting
really good at it
hey what'd you think of uh michael not
disagreed on this uh what'd you think of
of the timing of the dolphins going into
a time i i thought it was curious
because i know i know how the movie ends
with fitz but it was kind of just
getting good and the dolphins are
competitive i felt like they didn't have
to turn it over now what'd you think of
that move
it made me wonder if they
kind of sketched this out ahead of time
and i i don't know that that's not
inside info but
it didn't seem like there was a clear
football reason to do it and if you were
gonna go to him why not do it earlier
even because
you know fitz is gonna be fits
but
they've been pretty frisky i i think as
a team
and
because of their buy coming this week it
just made me wonder if there had been a
meeting
at some point that said
hey it would be awfully nice if we could
get him in there after the bye week and
i don't know if that's a great reason to
do something that may not matter if to a
play as well we'll sort of never know if
it was good process or not but
it seemed like curious timing and there
might have been a little bit of
foresight
was what it made me think yeah
saying
hey norah thank you so much it is always
michael i was saying it's always such a
good vibe when you hang out with us like
you really are a sister from another
mister
we were just talking about
we appreciate you thanks for making the
show best part of the show
that's right thanks guys had to come
back all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports